Par l'attaque surprise de Pearl Harbor, les Japonais espèrent briser la puissance militaire américaine et prévenir toutes représailles.
Malheureusement, c'est un échec total.
Les Japonais réussissent à couler ou gravement endommager sept vieux navires de guerre américains.
Mais la bataille ayant lieu dans un port,
la majeure partie des membres d'équipage est sauvée, et seuls deux bâtiments sur l'ensemble de la flotte sont détruits.
Même les installations militaires côtières survivent aux raids aériens.
De plus, cette violation du territoire américain unit le pays tout entier qui déclare la guerre à l'empire du Soleil Levant.
En outre, la destruction des navires de guerre américains,
oblige l'US Navy à utiliser ses nouveaux porte-avions comme pilier de sa flotte du Pacifique, plus modernes.
Les porte-avions "Lexington" et "Saratoga", tous deux construits en 1927,
et l'"Enterprise", plus moderne, sont en patrouille au large
lorsque le raid aérien survient. Ils sont par conséquent épargnés.
En 1942, les sisterships de l'Enterprise, le "Yorktown" et le "Hornet", récemment mis à l'eau viennent compléter la flotte du Pacifique.
Ces porte-avions sont spécialement conçus pour mener des offensives, car ils peuvent transporter un grand nombre de chasseurs de bombardiers.
L'amiral Chester William Nimitz, est le commandant en chef de la flotte américaine du Pacifique en 1942.
En quelques semaines, ce brillant officier, convaincu d'une victoire alliée, rétabli le moral des troupes.
Peu après son entrée en fonction, l'amiral Nimitz décide de mener une série de raids aériens sur les îles du Pacifique occupées par les Japonais.
Hormis titiller les Japonais, la principale raison de ces raids est de maintenir le moral de son équipage, et de le rendre opérationnel
sur le terrain.
A plusieurs occasions, sa flotte attaque les bases japonaises, situées dans les îles Gilbert et Marshall,
puis en Mars, c'est au tour des îles Marcus et Wake.
Ces raids aériens sont importants, et les dommages infligés à l'ennemi au cours des premiers mois de l'année 1942 sont considérables.
Les stratèges japonais redoutent plus que tout que leur pays subisse une attaque aérienne américaine.
Mais ces craintes deviennent une certitude le 18 avril 1942,
lorsque seize bombardiers moyens B-25 "Mitchell" attaquent Tokyo.
Cette flotte est sous le commandement du lieutenant colonel James Doolittle.
Plus surprenant encore, ces bombardiers d'un poids de 12 tonnes, et prévus pour décoller depuis la terre ferme,
réussissent à s'élever depuis le pont d'envol du porte-avions USS "Hortnet".
Le cœur même de la capitale japonaise est touchée. Bien que les dégâts soient faibles, l'impact sur le moral des habitants est énorme.
Le peuple est si effaré, que le commandant de la flotte japonaise,
l'amiral Yamamoto, est autorisé à mettre en oeuvre son grand plan :
un dernier affrontement entre les flottes japonaises et américaines.
Mais ce que l'amiral nippon n'a pas prévu, c'est que son grand plan sera bien vite découvert par l'ennemi.
Dès la fin du mois d'Avril, les services secrets américains sont capables de décrypter
85% des signaux japonais.
Ce décryptage, à lui seul, confère aux Américains un avantage considérable sur leurs ennemis.
En effet, les services secrets américains découvrent qu'une importante offensive est prévue dans le Sud-Ouest du Pacifique.
Les casseurs de code us confirment que Port Moresby sera la cible d'une attaque japonaise,
ainsi que les îles Salomon.
De ces deux forteresses, les Japonais, seront capables de dominer voir envahir le nord de l’Australie.
Le plan japonais consiste à couper l’Australie des Etats-Unis, tout d'abord en assiégeant Port Moresby,
puis en établissant une base aéronavale sur la petite île de Tulagi, dépendante des îles Salomon.
Puis les japonais occuperont des points stratégiques en nouvelle calédonie à vanuatu et dans les îles fidji
Afin de mettre en place cette offensive les japonais constituent une force d'invasion qui comprend une formidable et ce cadre d' attaque
composée de six destroyers moderne de trois croiseurs lourds et des grands porte-avions chocat coup les we 4
Ces deux porte avions peuvent transporter jusqu'à 133 avions
La force d'invasion devant se rendre à port moresby
partira de ras bol et la force d'attac quant à elle partira de lille de truck
appartenant aux îles caroline située à quelques 1600 km au nord-est de la nouvelle guinée
Les américains réagissent rapidement et partent à la poursuite des japonais
l'amiral limite envoie une force navale scindé en trois expéditions dans la mer de corail
le contre-amiral frank ji fletcher naviguant sur le porte-avions new york times en tête de la task force
17 est chargé du commandement tactique de l'ensemble de l'escadre
Le 1er mai 1942 la tf 17 rejoint la tf cause sous le commandement du contre-amiral fitch
naviguant au sud des îles salomon sur le porte-avions lexington
les deux porte avions pouvant accueillir chacun 141 appareils sont escortés de 5 3 heures et de 11 destroyer
Ces deux task force seront rejoindre plus tard dans la journée
par une escadre américano australienne de croiseurs et de destroyers sous le commandement du contre amiral john place
Le 3 mai les japonais occupent la petite île de toula guise sans rencontrer d'opposition
le lendemain ils sont bombardés par des avions ayant décollé du york times
Ce raid mené par les américains réussit à couver un destroyer et plusieurs autres navires de taille inférieure
mais les alliés ne pourront plus prendre les japonais par surprise
ces derniers savent désormais qu'au moins un porte avions américain croiser dans les parages
Les 5 et 6 mai 1942 les avions d'observation américain japonais se cherche en vain
Ce n'est que le 7 mai 1942 que les antagonistes finissent par se rencontrer
les deux camps s'offriront tout autant de ce contact à la suite de maladresses et d'accidents peu après 7 heures un avion d'observation
japonais pensent avoir repéré un porte avions ennemis au sud-ouest de l'île de guadalcanal
Le contre-amiral arts a chargé du commandement des porte avions japonais sho kacou et louis kacou lance un assaut de grande envergure
51 bombardier escorté par 18 chasseurs 0 quitté pont d'envol
Les navires repéré par les japonais sont en fait le pétrolier us s né au chaud et un croiseur des scores de cible facile
Pendant que cette attaque se prépare le contre-amiral haras apprend que la véritable 17e escadre américaines naviguent plus au nord-ouest
tout ce que haras peuvent faire c'est attendre patiemment que ces avions reviennent
Mais les japonais ne sont pas les seuls à commettre une erreur
à 8h15 un avion de reconnaissance américain
rapporte les positions de deux porte-avions japonais est de 4 croiseur lourd
juste au nord de l'île demi cisma près de la pointe est de la nouvelle guinée
le contre-amiral
fletcher au commandement de yorkton est convaincu d'avoir repéré la force d'invasion japonaise et lance également une attaque de grande envergure
près de lille
93 avion sans vol new york dan et du lexington
en réalité l'avion de reconnaissance us n'a repéré qu'une force japonaise de soutien composé de deux croiseurs et de deux destroyers
mais heureusement cette erreur est réparée par le lieutenant-colonel
hamilton chargé du commandement de l'escadrille de bombardements du lexington
alors que le porte-avions se dirige vers la forge japonaise le soutien
hamilton met le cap vers l'est où il aperçoit une force beaucoup plus importante
Une force de couverture pour l'invasion de port moresby sous le commandement du contre-amiral à rim au togo tôt
naviguant sur le porte-avions chaud
Les avions américains change aussitôt de trajectoire
au début le show facilement manoeuvrable réussi à esquiver les tirs américains
mais cela ne durera qu'un temps il porte avions finira par être coulé
Entre temps franck fletcher donne à l'escadre américano australienne sous le commandement du contre-amiral créé
l'ordre de contrer la force d'invasion de port moresby
la force de crise est attaquée par les japonais décollant de ras bol puis malheureusement
par db 26 américains partis d'australie est prononcée navire pour des bâtiments ennemis par chance
aucune de ces deux attaques ne lui est fatale
le 7 mai les japonais comme est une seconde bévue surprenante des avions japonais patrouillant à l'affût de la flotte américaine
repère le jordaan mais le pronom pour un des leurs ils tentent de s'y poser dix de ces avions seront abattus
La destruction du show et la présence d'une force américano australienne au large de port moresby
ainsi que le chef de la force d'invasion japonaise le vice amiral inouï et a différé l'invasion de la ville
Tôt le matin du 8 mai 1942 les forces ennemies finissent par se localiser mutuellement
à la suite de la destruction du show chaque camp ne possède plus que deux porte-avions mais les japonais n'ont que 95 avions opérationnel
contre 118 du côté américain
Peu après 9 heures les forces aériennes des deux camps d'école ainsi commence la bataille de la mer de corail
L'attak japonaise endommage gravement le yorktown et le lexington
Le yorktown réussi grâce à une manoeuvre habile à éviter les torpilles japonaise mais les bombes explosant près du navire
l'endommagent gravement en dessous de la ligne de flottaison
une autre bombe traverse quatre pompes et finit par exploser faisant prendre sept morts et 33 blessés
Le lexington plus imposant et - manoeuvrable que le yart âme est touché par deux torpilles
ainsi que par plusieurs bombes et donne de la bande
Pendant ce temps les pilotes américains lancent une attaque sur les porte-avions japonais
Le louis kacou le vaisseau amiral et dissimulés par des trombes d'eau c'est donc son sistership
le show kacou qui sera la cible de l'ensemble de la flotte aérienne américaine
Les quelques chasseurs 0 défendant la flotte japonaise
parviennent à maintenir la première vague de dévastateur américain à distance pour que leurs torpilles n'atteignent pas leur cible
mais la seconde vague de bombardiers en piqué dao tu laisses qui suit connaît plus de succès
le pilote d'un dao tu laisses le lieutenant john powers a juré de couler un porte avions ennemis sol
pendant l'attaqué du choca coup ils descendent en piqué pour attaquer le bâtiment de près
lâchant une bombe à seulement 90 mètres au dessous du pont du porte avions
L'explosion qui s'ensuit cause malheureusement la mort du lieutenant john power dont l'avion s'est abîmé en pleine mer
mais les dommages causés au pont du porte avions sont tellement importants que les avions sont désormais incapables de décoller
D'autres combes viendront terminer le travail de lieutenant le show kacou doit se retirer de la bataille
sans couverture aérienne
le vice-amiral inouye et doit rappeler ses troupes et interrompre l'invasion
La bataille de la mer de corail est un succès stratégique pour les américains mais malheureusement un grave incident
viendra ternir ce succès
deux heures après le retour du dernier avion américain le lexington est victime d'une grosse explosion
Ironie du sort cette déflagration n'est pas dû à une attaque ennemie mais le fait d'une simple étincelle provenant d'un générateur
qui par mégarde n'avait pas été arrêtée
à cause du pétrole ainsi que des vapeur s'échappant du réservoir percé un incendie se déclare
l'équipage mettra 24 heures à le circonscrire
mais les dommages sont tellement importants que l'équipage doit abandonner le porte-avions
2735 comme seront sauvés mais 216 périront dans les flammes du brasier
le porte-avions est achevée par une torpille lancée par un destroyer américain
L'amérique a perdu un porte avions un tanker est un destroyer alors que chez les japonais un porte avions un destroyer ont coulé
mais du côté américain les pertes humaines s'élève seulement si l'on peut dire à
564 marins et pilotes alors que 1074 soldats du mikado ont péri au cours de la bataille de la mer de corail
le japon a également perdu 77 avions alors que le nombre d'appareils a battu du côté américain s'élève à 66
lors de la bataille de la mer de corail les alliés réussissent empêcher l'invasion de port moresby et par conséquent celle de l'australie
la bataille de la mer de corail est la première livrée en pleine mer ou les deux flottes
s'affrontant ne se voit pas et compte uniquement sur leur aviation pour abattre l'ennemi
Les américains ont rapidement maîtrisé ce nouveau type de combats navals et honte à nouveau récidivé un peu plus tard
En fait pas si tard que ça
à la suite de la bataille de la mer de corail
les amiraux japonais prépare aussitôt une autre offensive au cours de laquelle il espère venir à bout de la flotte américaine du pacifique
une bonne fois pour toutes en attaquant l'atoll de midway
à l'ouest des îles hawaï les japonais espère tromper la flotte américaine du pacifique en l'attirant en pleine mer pour la détruire
Le 20 mai 1942 les stations d'écouté alliés basée près du pacifique
interceptent un long signal radio émis en morse
envoyé par l'amiral il sort ou coup yamamoto à sa flotte
le message est transmis à la combattent intelligence unit basé à pearl harbor pour être déchiffrées
le message révèle que la flotte japonaise est sur le point de lancer une puissante attaque sur l'atoll de midway
ainsi qu'une attaque de diversion dans les îles aléoutiennes situées à l'ouest de l'alaska
La base aéronavale de dutch harbor dans les îles aléoutiennes
sera la cible d'une attaque le 3 juin et la base aérienne de midway le lendemain
l'opération my l'attaquent de midway y présente toutes les caractéristiques d'un plan japonais
sa complexité les diverses hypothèses émises sur la réaction des américains et l'incapacité à concentrer leurs forces
Malgré ces points négatifs le plan aurait pu fonctionner si les américains n'avaient pas découvert ses secrets
le choix même de midway n'est pas justifiée un des capitaines de porte-avions de l'amiral yamamoto
qualifie midway y d'opérations impossible et inutile
mais alors que les stratèges japonais décide des points d'attac leurs plans sont rattrapés par les événements extérieurs
leur aide james doolittle lancé sur tokyo en avril
1942 avait mis l'empereur du japon en danger les généraux et amiraux japonais savent que la moindre faille dans la défense japonaise
doit être comblé
l'amiral yamamoto met alors au point un plan
Pendant qu'une partie de la flotte japonaise lancera une offensive sur midway le reste fera diversion en prenant pour cible les îles aléoutiennes
si les japonais réussit à s'emparer de midway ce sera une menace pour la base aéronavale de pearl harbor
et obligera l'amiral nimitz à reprendre midway
C'est alors que la force japonaise du pacifique forte de son aviation basée sur l'île l'attendra de pied ferme
Grâce à son piège l'amiral yamamoto
réussir à ce qu'il a raté à pearl harbor à savoir détruire la puissante flotte américaine du pacifique
il est persuadé qu'après la destruction de la flotte de l'amiral nimitz la côte ouest des états unis sera à la merci des japonais
Le président roosevelt n'aura alors d'autre alternative que de demander la paix selon les hypothèses des japonais
I saw roucou yamamoto implique la quasi totalité de la flotte japonaise dans son plan
160 navires de guerre dont huit porte avions et plus de 400 avions
la flotte est divisé en 5 forces de combat en tête de la flotte se trouve la force d'attaqué
composé de quatre porte avions est de 225 bombardier
Ces derniers devront bombardé midway avant que la force d'invasion
composé de cinq mille hommes débarquent les douze navires de transport
la force d'invasion sera protégé par deux forces de soutien
chacune à une distance de 80 km à 950 km de cette force se tiendra la principale escadre japonaise
composée de cette cuirasse et
son rôle sera de venir à bout des quelques irréductibles qui survivraient à l'attack des bombardiers
Sachant que la chance n'est pas de ce côté
geyster n'imite mise tout sur les porte-avions et leur capacité de mener des attaques de longue portée
Il décide de laisser les navires les plus longs au mouillage sur la côte ouest américaine afin de ne pas handicaper la flotte
L'amiral divise la flotte américaine en deux casques forces de combat
la tf 16 former des porte-avions hornet enterprises et la terre 17 conduite par le yorktown
Le 28 mai 1942 la task force 16 guide pearl harbor
mais la tf 17 prend du retard en raison de réparations nécessaires sur le yacht comme
séquelle de la bataille de la mer des corail
L'équipage basé à pearl harbor annonce à l'amiral limites que les réparations prendront encore six semaines
mais ce dernier exige qu'elle soit exécutée en 24 heures
C'est chose faite grâce au travail acharné de l'équipage
le 30 mai sous le commandement du contre-amiral frank fletcher le york times quitte le port
une fois en mer il prend le commandement tactique d2 et ce cadre
vous agirez en calculant les risques avait ordonné chester nimitz
Avertie par les services secrets
la flotte américaine atteint midway bien avant que les sous-marins japonais ait pu établir un cordon à l'ouest de hawaï pour repérer l'ennemi
L'île de midway petit avant poste entre l'état de hawaii et le japon est la sentinelle de pearl harbor
la base aérienne est en état d' alerte
les américains basés ici savent que quelque part entre les nuages et l'horizon va se profiler l'ombre de la flotte nippone
Les services secrets les ont averti que l'attaqué prévue pour le lendemain
La garnison de midway a été renforcée la veille au soir des forteresses volantes b17 ont atterri
Des sept les b 17 sont sur la piste de décollage où ils sont approvisionnés en carburants
les bombes sont chargés à bord des avions et les mitrailleuses sont rechargées
dès que l'ennemi sera repéré les b 17 seront prêts à lancer l'offensive
au cours de sa patrouille ce matin là l'enseigne jack quaid aux commandes d'un pb y catalina de reconnaissance
parcours les cieux à la recherche de la flotte ennemie
à 9 heures il repère les navires de transport et les croiseurs d'escort de la force d'invasion japonaise
Un message est aussitôt envoyé à l'amiral qui se trouvaient à bord du organes
mais ce n'est pas cela qui intéresse franck est cher mais bien la force d' attaques de porte avions
c'est pourquoi ils envoient les forteresses volantes attaqué la force d'invasion
Alors que les bombardiers s'élance sur la piste de décollage le contre-amiral apprend que l'attak de diversion planifiée par les japonais a déjà commencé
Tôt le matin même les japonais ont attaqué les îles aléoutiennes
Les bombardiers torpilleur et les chasseurs 0 du porte-avions julio jo
fonde sur la base aéronavale américaine de deux chars bord dans les îles du renard
les objectifs nippons sont les réservoirs de pétrole les casernes l'hôpital et l'église
cependant les pilotes inexpérimentés de l'autre porte avions de la force le jauniaux sont portées disparues
Les flying boat américains avaient repéré les japonais mais il était trop loin des navires américains et des bases aériennes pour pouvoir mener des offensives
efficace
Toutefois l'amiral nimitz ne se laisse pas abuser par cette diversion
et refuse de priver midway d'importantes forces en les envoyant au nord
Le 4 juin 1940 de la principale cible de la flotte américaine
à savoir la force d' attaques de porte-avions japonaise sous le commandement de l'amiral nagumo zigzag à travers un épais brouillard
ignorant totalement que la flotte ennemie l'attend non loin de là
aux petites heures du matin les conditions météorologiques s'améliorent à 4h30 l'amiral nagumo lance sa première offensive
108 avions décollent du porte-avions pour attaquer mais doit elle
Ils apparaissent presque aussitôt sur le radar de la base américaine
les héros sorte de derrière les nuages et la défense de lille agit aussi tôt
Les chasseurs basé à midway prennent l'air également pour affronter l'ennemi
Les bâtiments de l'aérodrome et la garnison subissent d'importants dommages mais la piste d'aviation est intacte
quelques avions de transport sont endommagés mais la majeure partie des chasseurs et des bombardiers sont en vol pendant l'attaqué
Bien que l'île de midway il ne soit plus qu'un mur de flammes sur l'océan l'étendue des dégâts reste limitée
L'amiral nagumo est en mauvaise posture
sa première offensive n'a pas réussi à détruire la piste déviation comme prévu cette dernière est toujours opérationnel
il doit donc porter un second coup
sur les conseils de l'amiral yamamoto
il a conservé ses meilleurs pilotes et ses appareils cat est armé de torpilles au cas où la flotte américaine arriverait plus tôt que prévu
Pourtant ces avions d'observation leur père qu'aucun navire us mais il doit finir de détruire la base de midway
mais avant même qu'il ait pu prendre une décision les américains décident pour lui
Les bombardiers ayant décollé de midway arrive et attaque si bien qu'ils ne détruisent pas le navire ils changent le cours de la bataille
Le commandant japonais ordonne que la seconde vague de bombardier torpilleur soirée armés de bombes pour la seconde offensive sur meego est
à 7h28 15 minutes après les ordres du commandant japonais un des avions d'observation nippon repères dix navires de guerre américains
à environ 200 milles au nord-est des porte avions japonais
Malheureusement cet avion d'observation japonais avait été catapulté une demi heure en retard le matin même
s'il avait décollé en temps et en heure voulu
il aurait repéré les navires américains une demi heure plus tôt et l'aurait signalé avant que les bombardiers soit envoyée
si cela avait été le cas
l'amiral nagumo aurait certainement lancer ses avions contre la flotte américaine et le cours de la bataille et de l'ensemble de la guerre du pacifique
en eût été changée
L'amiral est à nouveau face à un dilemme doit-il lancé une offensive contre la flotte américaine ou se concentrer sur la tacc de midway
Il ordonne de ne pas ré armes et les avions mais une autre question se pose à lui la flotte américaine
comprend tels des porte avions
Ces craintes sont fondées
lorsqu à 8h20 un avion de reconnaissance rapporte que la flotte ennemie compte un navire qui semble être un porte avions
Cette nouvelle n'aurait pas pu arriver à un pire moment
La première vague d'avions japonais revient de midway où elle menait une offensive et doit affronter pour se ravitailler en carburant
les bombardiers opérationnel devront donc voler sans être escorté de chasseurs et sont seulement armés de bombes et non de torpilles
Dès 9 heures 18 les ponts des porte avions japonais sont remplies l'avion certains sont réarmer
d'autres sont approvisionnées en carburants les porte avions sont littéralement des bombes flottantes
à l'insu de son homologue japonais franck fletcher lance ses avions et est prête à attaquer à tout moment
Du côté japonais on apprend que le pb y catalina de reconnaissance a rapporté la position des porte avions japonais
à 5h30 4 le matin même
frank feltscher a envoyé le hornet l enterprise mené une offensive
pendant que le yorktown attend le retour de l'avion d'observation à 7 le hornet
enterprises encore à une bonne distance des porte avions japonais lance leurs avions cent cinquante deux appareils en tout
les américains savent que les avions japonais ont rejoint les porte-avions après l'offensive lancée sur midway
mais ils prennent malgré tout le risque de lancer leurs avions une telle distance
Ces hommes vont mener une des batailles aériennes n'est plus décisif de l'histoire
Mais ce que ces pilotes ne savent pas c'est que l'amiral nagumo a décidé de se dérouter lorsqu'il a ordonné de ravitailler ses avions
résultat les cadres rock aérien de la tf 16 ont quelques difficultés à localiser leur cible
à 9h28 les deux escadrille d'avions torpilleur américains ayant décollé de l'hournède
survole la flotte japonaise et attaque en piqué
Les japonais lance leurs chasseurs 0 dans le but de repousser les bombardiers américains une bataille sans pitié se livre dans le ciel
Dès 9h45 une autre vague de bombardier torpilleur quitte l'inter prize et atteint la flotte japonaise
suivie d'une autre vague partie de yorkton à 10h15
Les pertes côté américain qui sont élevés les chasseurs et la défense anti-aérienne des navires japonais
abattent un bon nombre d'avions ennemis
seuls 4 des avions ayant quitté länder prize reviennent les pertes du hornet et du york times sont également lourde
Et ceux qui reviennent doivent encore réussir à poser leurs avions endommagée sur les ponts mobiles des porte avions
Ce pilote par exemple n'a pas eu de chance
Certains racontent en feu
Aussi incroyable que cela puisse paraître ce pilote s'en est tiré
Le capitaine de corvette mccluskey
scrutent le ciel étincelant du pacifique au nord-est de l'île de midway
il est en tête d'une escadrille de 33 bombardier de l'inter prize et il est perdu il doit absolument prendre une décision
Il n'a rien trouvé là où ils s'attendaient à trouver l'ennemi et ces avions vont bientôt devoir faire demi-tour pour ravitailler
mais le capitaine mccluskey a une intuition et décide de poursuivre ses recherches un peu plus vers l'ouest
cela finit par payer
L'amiral nimitz
qualifiera par la suite ce choix comme étant la décision la plus importante de la bataille
quelques minutes plus tard le capitaine mccluskey repère le sillage d'un destroyer ennemis et le suit
peu après 10 heures il aperçoit enfin les porte avions japonais
les premières vagues de bombardier américain qui venait de lancer une offensive avait subi de lourdes pertes
la plupart des dévastateur zh peu maniable avait été abattu par des chasseurs 0
mais cette première attaque avait permis à l'escadrille de mccluskey dette sur les lieux sans se faire repérer
rejoint par 17 bombardier du roc down le capitaine n'aurait pas pu arriver à un meilleur moment
les ponts des porte avions japonais contiennent près d'une centaine d'appareils il se prépare à lancer leurs propres principes sur les porte-avions américain
tous sont chargés d'explosifs et de carburant à indice d'octane élevé
la moindre étincelle les transformeraient littéralement en enfer flottant
Alors que les porte avions japonais se positionne dans l'acte du vent pour lancer leurs avions
cinq ans bombardier américain tombe du ciel comme des faucons fondant sur leur proie
Les premiers tirs transforme les porte avions accueilli gaga et sort your hands véritable torche flottante comme le raconte un marin japonais
J'ai d'abord entendu le terrible grondement des bombardiers puis l'explosion d'un tir direct
il y à une lumière éblouissante puis une seconde explosion encore plus puissante que la première
En quelques minutes la majeure partie de la première flotte aérienne japonaise est anéanti
le quatrième porte avions le et riou a échappé à l'attaqué mais tente une contre-offensive désespéré
à midi le et riou lens et avion contre le york times
Au cours de cette offensive le yorktown tente désespérément de manoeuvrer mais il ne parvient pas à éviter plusieurs coups directs
On peut voir sur ces images comment se porte avions malgré sa taille change rapidement de cap grâce à ces machines
L'on peut voir aussi les effets d'une bombe explose en tout près de yorkton
regarder à gauche sur votre écran comment l'avion sur le pont et secouer
Le yorktown lutte difficilement pour survivre aux attaques des bombardiers mais en vain
à 14h40 à la suite du coup direct d'un avions torpilleurs
le york times est tellement endommagé que le contre-amiral n'a d'autre solution que d'ordonner son évacuation
Il remet le commandement à l'amiral ce drame ce commandant de la task force 16
à 17 heures l'amiral lance ses avions depuis le hornet enterprises
Leur mission en finir avec le et rhume
L'offensive américaine prend les japonais au dépourvu
une fois encore leur avion sont sur le pont d'envol car il se prépare à lancer une attaque aérienne sur les porte-avions américain encore
opérationnels à la tombée de la nuit
Quatre tirs directs font de ces ponts un mur de flammes
Le hiryu subi de lourdes pertes et ne pourra être réparé
Au cours de la nuit du 4 juin alors que les équipages du hornet et de l'interprète
préparent leur avion pour la bataille du lendemain les porte-avions sorgues rica gars commencent leur lente descente dans les eaux de l'océan
Alors que le soleil montre ses premiers rayons le 5 juin 1940 de la flotte américaine apprend que le hiryu
brûlant encore telle une torche sombre rapidement
peu de temps après les américains sont informés que le dernier porte avions japonais
le haka guy a subi le même sort que les trois autres
quatre des meilleurs porte avions japonais ont été détruits
Le 6 juin ils seront cool yamamoto donne l'ordre à l'ensemble de la flotte de se retirer
mais les avions américains auront tout de même le temps d'attaquer deux croiseurs japonais l'un sera cool et l'autre sera gravement endommagés
Le matin du 7 juin
l'équipe chargée de la sécurité montent à bord du hms york tonnes pour réparer les avaries
mais peu de temps après le porte-avions sera torpillé par un sous marin nippon et sombrera
Ce même jour les japonais accostent les îles deux atouts et kiska appartenant aux îles aléoutiennes
et abritant seulement une station météo
Ces deux îles à l'extrême ouest des aléoutiennes sont tellement secondaire que le département japonais rap eu de conséquence du côté américain
à un tel point que les américains et leurs trous qui ont eu connaissance du débarquement japonais au bout du quatrième jour
n'ont entrepris aucun effort immédiat pour rejoindre milan
Alors que les deux camps considère la bataille de la mer de corail comme une victoire celle de midway y ne fait aucun doute
les etats-unis ont détruit la principale force d' attaque japonaise composée de quatre porte avions d'un croiseur lourd
de 3 122 avions et de près de cinq mille marins et officiers
La flotte américaine du pacifique loin d'être détruite comme l'amiral yamamoto l'avait promis vient de gagner une bataille remarquable
Qui plus est comme cela a souvent été le cas dans l'histoire des guerres
les américains ont remporté une victoire face à un ennemi largement supérieures en nombre
L'effort japonais est compromis par une stratégie compliqué des erreurs tactiques
et de la déveine alors que les américains bénéficie d'excellents services secrets d'une très bonne organisation
navale d'un excellent commandement tactique et surtout de beaucoup de chance
Malgré la destruction d'un porte-avions
237 appareils et de la perte de 307 hommes les américains ont changé le cours de la guerre du pacifique
le japon ne peut plus prendre le risque de sacrifier une grande flotte face à une flotte d'action et sera désormais sur la défensive
Lorsque le japon aura fini de reconstruire sa marine la flotte américaine sera déjà devenue la puissance
intouchable que l'amiral ils sauront coup yamamoto
redoutait tant
Et